so h7 the threat is very simple catch 8
queen h3 and queen 7 mate
so you have to take on g6 that's for
sure
can you go no
i was going to say no rook d5 instead of
fg but it doesn't it doesn't help
just to stop your threat rock d5
and yeah i'm not sure what i gained we
need three still but okay
it's not made this way but it will be
another way
okay at least the game doesn't end maybe
let's talk although it should end
bishop c2 played by mr magnus and the
computer
not a big fan as far as i could it's
gonna be fun okay
here we go again
i think okay seven was um tequila move
but this line we had rook h7 f36 rook d5
26 look clean enough no like yeah i
thought
everything bishop c2 queen f2 played by
radick
back in business
was that missed let's see if there's any
headshakes
can i can i give a check here what do
you do king f7 yeah
because vocab 7 it's not really um
ah and king h8 there's queen f2 which is
nice or
rook h72 but no i mean if instead of
rook f7 king h8 yeah
exactly here changes queen f2
okay f2 okay seven mate here
so here king f7 is basically easily move
otherwise you lose that bonus check
nothing direct apparently we should have
five coin h4
yeah exactly and and
again f1 still looks bad but okay f1 k8
what else
and the king will hide we have no tricks
not f6
i think
yeah even king headshots but
yeah of course what's wrong with queen
f6 yes highly
too many pieces huh
so quick f2 could have been missed by
magnus carlsen